this is Piers Morgan uncensored and this
is the interview the entire world has
been talking about Cristiano Ronaldo one
on one
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored welcome to a special edition
of Piers Morgan on census Cristiano
Ronaldo is a football Mega star in my
opinion the greatest player to ever
grace the game he's also one of the most
famous people on the planet
he saw the toughest year of his life on
and off the pitch facing personal
tragedy and the barrage of criticism
from fans pundits even his own coaches
everyone else has had their say now it's
his turn and Cristiano is most
definitely uncensored
no no let me start just by asking you
why are you doing this interview with me
because I think it's the time
to say something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
I don't say that in public
well I like you too and I appreciate it
because I think that you've had to
sustain a lot of criticism this year in
particular probably more than any stage
in your career and I think it's time to
set the record straight and to clear up
a few things not least I suspect for the
fans of Manchester United you must be
wondering what the hell's been going on
oh as I as I say many many times the
fans they always I'm always gonna
say good about them they are
the most important things in a football
you play for them they're always in my
side
I feel that every time when I go when I
walk in the streets the fans coming to
me and they appreciate
what I did what I do for football and
for me it's the most important in
football the fans for me is everything
I want to take you back to last year
last summer your Juventus
and there's massive speculation about
where you're going to go
and the big rumor is that you're going
to go to Manchester City so first of all
how close was that to happening
well honestly
um
it was close
it was close is something that they
spoke a lot
and Guardiola say
two weeks ago I guess that they try
they try hard to have me
but as you know as my history in
Manchester United your hearts you're
feeling the way the history that you did
before
make the difference and of course as
well Sir Alex Ferguson
so I was I was surprised in the same way
but it was conscious decision uh because
the hearts speak speaking loud in that
moment you were Manchester United Legend
So when you say your heart LED you it's
because of that the history you have
with the club and the relationship you
maintained with Sir Alex with the fans
I think it was it was the key it was the
the difference in that moment but I
cannot be loyal if I would I wouldn't
say that Manchester City wasn't close
but
I think I I did
conscious decision
um I don't regret
at some point
and as you mentioned before Sarah Alex
Ferguson was was the key and she's why
did you speak to him before you yes I
did yes I did I spoke I spoke with them
with him and
um what did he say to you to try and
persuade you he said to me that uh
um
it's it's impossible for you to come to
Manchester City
and I say okay boss
so I took the decisions and I repeat
with very I was with conscience that
it was a
a good decision
you came back and it couldn't have
started better you played it Old
Trafford yeah you won 4-1 against
Newcastle you scored twice
Alex Sir Alex was there loving it
obviously the return of the prodigal son
your mother was there the return of her
own son uh your mother was crying
obviously obviously yes but what a
comeback uh how did that feel that day
when when you came off the pitch well
that feeling was amazing but not only
the day of the game I felt before the
week before that everything changed the
world speak about me Cristiano back home
back where they belong so it was a
special special moment to be back to
Manchester United to perform for
uh our fans and of course to score two
goals was the best welcome that I
received in Old Trafford it was Memorial
day and uh unbelievable day too the Viva
Ronaldo charm went up yes we were
Ronaldo you like hearing be back of
course I did yeah as I told you before
the fans for me they are everything
two things happened I think within 24
hours of you re-signing for United one
you broke the all-time record for shirt
sales in 24 hours you actually beat a
guy called Messi PSG you must have been
happy about that of course I did
as you know I'm
I'm I don't follow the records the
records follow me so it's good another
one in my in my book and the other one
was the Manchester United tweet
announcing that you were rejoining the
club was the most
Tweety or most liked tweet I think in
Twitter history
it's good as I told you before it was a
good moment nobody expect
because things
change around in my opinion in 72 hours
which is
you plan or they spoke not only
Manchester City but other clubs too
spoke about your name that you will
change Juventus for another club
but Manchester United wasn't there
wasn't in that part of that teams but
surprise everybody even me to be honest
after a few weeks
things weren't going well at Manchester
United the club just wasn't firing and
in the end Ole gun a solska the manager
got sacked and that's within like two
months of you coming back what were you
feeling about what was going on at
United and what did you feel generally
about the club itself and the state that
the club was in compared to when you'd
been there before
because to be honest when I I signed for
Manchester United I thought everything
was changed because it's 13 years that I
change
I was in Real Madrid nine years and
three in Juventus and when I arrived I
thought everything will be different you
know the technology the infrastructures
and everything but I was surprised
in a bad way let's say in that way
because I saw everything was the same
and Manchester it wasn't it wasn't in
that moment that as you mentioned that
olly was suck Michael Carrick he assumed
the the job for to to games Villarreal
and Chelsea away
and everything was was so fast but
surprised me a lot instability in a club
everything was kind of the same that I
that I hadn't moved on no they they
stopped on on the clock in my opinion
which is something that that surprised
me I didn't expect
and um
slowly and slowly they start to change
even even the the windows the new
players and what stuff was tough for me
because I didn't expect that and uh
because when you were there before
if Manchester United wanted a player
under Sir Alex Ferguson they normally
got their man right now it's a very
different environment after many years
of failure since Sir Alex retired
United weren't getting the top players
anymore
so were you surprised by that Dynamic
changing as well because you would have
been used before to them if they wanted
top players they got them I was
surprised I thought when I signed that
they sign in that year Sancho and Varan
plus me that things will be
in the way that Manchester should be
as you mentioned well Sarah Alex version
left a big gap in the club not only Sir
Alex Fergus but one person that I
thought make the difference David Gill
the president a very very good man
and the structure around saralex
fragrance was very important too
I knew it that Manchester United wasn't
the same
but I don't
see that it was so big up so big things
that
go through by the last 10 years
and it was the thing that surprised me
more to be honest with little things
like even the swimming pool the players
use the saunas all these facilities
nothing had changed since you'd left in
2009 nothing changed surprisingly
natural only the pulled the jacuzzi even
the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is
it surprised me a lot I thought I will
see different things different as I
mentioned before technology
infrastructure
but unfortunately we see many
things that I'm used to see when I was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
you'd also of course as you said you've
been at Real Madrid and Juventus where
you saw them moving all the time to
progress with technology the latest
thing to improve performance levels so
you were able to compare what you'd
experienced there with what was not
happening at United
in the united they the progress was zero
in my opinion
to compare with Real Madrid and even
Juventus that
they follow
the recent world so the the technology
especially the terms of of training
nutrition and conditions of uh it
properly and to recover better than
before
surprised me Manchester right now to
compare with that club I think it's it's
behind in my opinion which is something
that surprised me a club with this
Dimension
um should be in the top of the tree in
my opinion and
they are not Unfortunately
they are not in that level but I hope
the next years they can reach
to be in a top level
up next Ronaldo scathing verdict almost
gone wrong at Manchester United
[Music]
when you look at I mean United have had
some of the best managers in the world
follow Sir Alex Ferguson and they've all
been relative failures compared to other
stages of their careers do you think
that partly that's down to the the
structural element of this that just
isn't the support that top managers need
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah Alex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
um Ollie
they buy they bring sport directive
Ralph regnick which is something that
nobody understands this guy is not even
a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive surprise not only
me but all the world you know well it
was a ridiculous decision wasn't it of
course in my opinion it's you have to be
honest if you're not if you're not even
a coach how you're gonna be the boss of
Manchester United it's something that I
should say that Manchester is not
followed not the right way to reach
successful like other teams like for
example Liverpool or Manchester City
Chelsea they are one step behind or two
because of this kind of mistakes in my
opinion that they should improve and
change probably the
the staff or or the people the
directives or presidents I don't know
who is the
was the problem there but still show a
lack of ambition to you when they
replaced oligonna solskar who a lot of
fans liked but he obviously wasn't
delivering the big titles that United
wanted and were used to but to a point
someone like Ralph Randy I mean I'd
never heard of him
and I'm thinking and I'm thinking if as
you heard of him no of course not you've
never heard of this guy nobody and the
people who I speak nobody knew it it was
him suddenly he's did you call him the
boss
of course I I respect we have to call
because he assumed the job
uh regardless the all the coaches that I
had in my career I call them boss
because if they assume the the job you
have to call in that way but in the end
deep deep inside me I I never saw him as
a boss because I saw some points that
I never agreed and he's stopped in the
time as well because if you're not
being a coach the the last the next five
years you're gonna you know you're gonna
lost the identity of to be a coach so
surprised me a lot but in the same way
don't surprise me a lot because if you
see the structures just keep they keep
in the same so the coaches didn't
surprise me but was a tough moment what
was the extraordinary was very quickly
after rannick took over
it started briefing journalists that you
weren't pressing enough
and that maybe it would be a good idea
if you moved on from the club and I'm
like who is this guy and why is he
saying this to the man who's scoring the
goals
to be honest basically something that I
I don't understand it's the new coaches
that coming around they think they find
the last Coca-Cola in the desert which
is that I don't understand the football
Dairy invents many many years so but I
respect any courts have a different
approach different opinions different
mentality but kind of some points that
you're you're not agree so I'm always
like that in my life I'm always been
besides the best coaches in the world
zidane and chalati Mourinho Fernando
Santos allegri
so I had kind of some experience because
I learned from them and when you see
some coaches that they're coming that
they want to Revolution the football are
not a Greek I I have my opinion they
agree out they don't they disagree but
it's part of the the business because
I'm in the end of the day I'm in a club
to win and uh with my experience I want
to help like always and I some coaches
that don't accept
and that you know it's part of the job
did he know what he was doing running or
not
at a club like United
no they don't
um
they knew with the club very well
but they don't know the main of the
dimension of the club inside the history
of the club
which is for me surprised me even more
which is when you the soccer all is so
scary you should bring a top manager not
sport directive do you think he was
right to get rid of solska or would you
have kept him up
well it's not well I love salskayer I
think it was a top person because what I
what I keep inside my heart it's the
heart of the persons and only for me is
a top person coach of course
it wasn't it didn't it didn't look for
what he
what he wants his Hearts his Hearts to
assume after Sir Alex Ferguson but I
think he did a good job for for sure you
need much more time but I'm never doubt
that you're going to be a good a good
coach in the future but it was a good
experience I was I was so pleased to
work with him even a short period
what about the younger players and and
specifically their mentality because it
seemed to me just from what I was
reading when you were originally at
Manchester United as a young 18 year old
that you had huge respect for the older
players
the Kings and these guys in the dressing
room and you would soak up
their experience their victim and so on
did you get that same
respect do you think from the younger
players I don't mean that they don't
respect the experienced players or the
oldest players I don't I don't I don't
think that word it's the the best one
but
they live in a different era I can't see
my kid they have 12 years old the
mentality are not the same they are not
suffered that what's the difference the
anger
I think the hunger I think that they
have the things more easily everything
it's easily they don't suffer and I
think it's they don't care I don't mean
only I feel in Manchester United but all
the teams all
all leagues in the world the the
youngest now they are not the same of my
generation but we cannot play blame them
because
it's part of the life you know the new
generation and um the the new
technologies that avoid
the distract them for another thing so
but they are not the same that they
listen but this is why we have two years
you listen from one side and they go
away from Another Side so
don't surprise me but in the same way
it's a little bit shame because if they
have the best examples in front of your
eyes and if they don't at least copy
what you did for me it's kind of it's
kind of weird because I remember when I
was 18 1920s I'm always looked to see
the best players when Mr Roy Ferdinand
roykin
and that gigs this is why you have the
successful that I have on longevity
because I take care of my body my
mentality my head
because I see these guys and I learn
from them
when you try and give advice to these
younger players what do you say to them
what do you what do you try and guide
them to be like
I think the best advice I'm not the kind
of guys to like to give advice is I
prefer to build as example yeah because
I'm I'm an example I'm there every
morning I do the same stuff I'm probably
the first ones to arrive and the last
one to to go out
I think
the the details speak for itself so
because as I told you before
um they'll listen one thing and in two
minutes they already forgot and do it
whatever they think it's it's it's
better this is why I say
I like to lead by example and someone's
they follow me not much but see I find
that I just find that incredible
that if I was a young footballer and I
had Cristiano Ronaldo at my club that I
wouldn't want to spend every second
watching him listening to him observing
the way you go about your business and
yet from what you're saying clearly
that's not they're not interested they
don't care
someone's yes but most of them know but
for me it's not surprised me don't
surprise me because they're not gonna
have longevity careers in my opinion
it's impossible it's impossible
to see for example my generation you see
many players they they reach 36 37 38 in
high level I think this generation
you're gonna count by your hands on many
gonna reach in that level because
this years of preparation it's helps a
lot who were the players in the world
that you most admire for their mental
strength their attitude
it's it's difficult question because I'm
I'm always can say what I see from my
highs for example if you tell me
what I see for example in Manchester
United I can mention probably download
his example is young but he's very
very professional and I'm not doubt that
they're gonna reach you're gonna have
longevity in football because he's he's
young he's smart intelligent and he's
very professional you have a few ones
more but like him it's it's difficult to
see probably Martinez
um casimiro's start is
um
but I will say dalot
coming next Ronaldo opens up on the
toughest moment of his life
[Music]
[Music]
so the Runnings come then it's your
second manager it's not working the
results aren't great you're still
scoring goals regularly for Manchester
United you're about the only one who is
but then you get hit by an awful episode
in your life probably the worst time of
your life
where your partner Georgina she's
pregnant with twins and is actually
giving birth to these two babies
and your baby son doesn't survive
and I don't think I can imagine I have
four kids you have a lot of children
you know you can't imagine a worse thing
to happen than to go a full term of a
pregnancy particularly for the poor
mother in that case but also for you
what was that like for you
that that time in your life is probably
the worst moment that I passed through
my life since my
my father died you know when you have a
kid that you expect that everything will
be normal and you have that uh problem
it's it's hard you know as human being
that I am in Georgina why we had quite
difficult moments because
we don't understand why happened to us
was difficult to be honest was was very
very difficult to to understand what's
going what's going on in that in that
period of our life
as you know the football carry on there
so fast many competitions the football
don't stop we are many many competitions
and pass through in that moment was
probably the most difficult moment that
I had in my life me and my my family
especially Geo that was was tough she
said she was giving an interview about
the new series of her TV show and she
said in an interview a big piece of my
heart shattered and I asked myself how I
could carry on I had the answer nearer
than I thought I looked into the eyes of
my children and there I saw the only way
of doing it being all together
yeah I I I saw too yeah this is why what
we did we I grew up my my family
especially Geo and um
we had the difficult moments but we say
listen we have more more kids we have
one that born Bella that we have to be
happy to I mean such a difficult
situation again where you're mourning
the terrible loss of your little baby
boy but also celebrating the birthday of
your beautiful daughter I try to explain
sometimes to my family and even my close
friends they say I never felt to be
happy and sad in the same moment yes I
never felt it is hard to explain
um so difficult so difficult it's you
don't know if you cry or you don't know
if you smile yes because it's something
that
you don't know how to react you don't
know what to do to be honest and of
course I remember very well that
I look like
I don't know the word that to Define
what I felt in that moment but it's it's
crazy feeling it's crazy emotional
but as I told you before I I
have to to old
that we had at least Bella yes which is
the most important one die and one
survive
but it was it's difficult to explain how
did you explain it all to your other
children they must have been so confused
about in the beginning do you arrive in
home and the kids start to say where's
another baby where's another baby of
course Cristiano had a conversation with
him
in the in the day
because he's 12 years old he knows and
he understands everything and I had a
nice conversation with him we cried
together in his bedroom
and he explained and this kind of
he don't understand you understand but
in the same way it was a little bit
confused the other ones in the beginning
in the table the kids start to say mom
where is the uh the other baby and Geo
in the beginning they start to say
because you know she she had a little
bit belly because they had two it's hard
process
and after one week I say you know let's
let's be frontal let's be honest with
the kids let's let's say that's uh Angel
which is the name they go to the to the
heaven
it's better to say in that way yeah and
uh we start to use that in that uh in
that way and the kids always understand
when we had shots in a table and they
say Daddy I did this for hand gel and
they they pawned out for the for this
guy which is I I say and I and I like it
the most because you know it's part of
the lives and I am not gonna lie to my
kids to say the true which is this was a
difficult process but in the same way
I become more more father more friendly
of them they become more
more close to his daddy especially me
with Georgine as well I was going to ask
you that because these things they can
they can't make or break relationships
because the grief can be so intense it
can Drive couples apart or we can bring
them closer
in my case it was more
was better in that way I become more
friendly
of Geo I was of course friend but I see
more more lovely for her and for my for
my kids and I start to see the life with
a different perspective you understand
which is coming the point of if you're
gonna ask me for sure
the prices and moments for example why I
didn't go to the prison so I'm gonna
come today but it was
just to finish in that that chapter was
the most difficult moment
the last since my dad died it was this
moment that I passed through the last
six months
do you feel your son is is with you in
spirit for sure for sure his ashes is
with me like my daddy they are here in
my house yes yes
is something that it's I want to hold
for the rest of my life I'm not throw to
the to the ocean or to the sea I keep
with me there next to my to my daddy
I've I don't know if you
you check have a small Church down and
you do yes I do like a little chapel yes
chapel and I keep my dad and my son do
you talk to them yes I do
um I I talk with them every time
and that they are in my side they are
you know they help me
to be a better man to be a better person
to be a better father and it's something
that I'm really really proud that the
message that they send me especially my
my son amazing
you had an extraordinary reaction from
football fans
obviously from Manchester United but I
think you must have been just so
surprised by the outpouring of not just
support but Liverpool fans sang on the
seventh minute of their next game You'll
Never Walk Alone the cop the great
Infamous enemy of Manchester United what
did you feel when you heard that I never
ever expect that never
I had the opportunity now to to say all
English Community thank you a lot for
that kind of that they had with me not
only Liverpool but all England I felt I
was arsenal when you played in on the
seventh minute the whole crowd I
received I received a letter from
the queen family as well really yes I do
which is from the queen itself yeah
family yeah and um
surprised me a lot offering their
condolences yes wow unbelievable this is
why I say I respect a lot the English
Community English people
because they've they've been very kind
with me and in that difficult moment on
my life
was spectacular the way they treat me me
and my family and that difficult moments
I I should say straight to the
commenting thank you to the Old English
community that helped me in that moment
the when the queen sadly died in
September you posted a very nice tribute
to her was part of the reason because of
of what they had of course in life with
you of course they've been so kind of
with me and um this is why I did what I
did
uh but it was unbelievable moment and
never ever gonna forget that moment
you have a little go Bella she's six
months old now
must be a great joy I made all that
terrible sadness unbelievable it was
another member in the family they are
the the shine of the house
and we are so proud May Georgina and all
all my kids they are they are very very
proud for them they are they are
spectacular beautiful
girl and we are so happy we are so so
happy we are we are happy Fathers you're
gonna have more
I'm not thinking now to thinking more
kids I think we we done but we never
know the future only Gods know but right
now we all want to to have a break to
enjoy this once because they are little
Bella six and the rest there are five
and Christiano 12. we want to enjoy a
little bit of these ones let's see the
future
it's very difficult to play top level
football at the best of times it's a
hard business and full public glare of
millions of people watching to have to
go back and play after this
must have been incredibly hard for you
even with your mental strength how did
you find that
difficult very difficult to to play
after that but as I always have good
support from my family and Georgina told
me go go to play go enjoy to do what you
like to do
you're gonna help for you to forgot
forget a little bit the situation
was difficult but in the same point I
think helps helps for you to you know to
don't think much about that even to
training was good but
as you know the
the football going so fast and you know
trainings games uh even the national
team the things going so fast you don't
even have a time to settle and say
what's going on you know
because the thing's going so fast but
was good help Georgina helped me a lot
to give me that possibility to say she's
a very strong woman yes Georgina yes I
mean really strong yes to to just to be
your partner it's probably not an easy
time a lot of the time with all the
attention all the time but to go through
what she's gone through and still
get up be there we help each other but
she struggle when he when she is young
which she now she look at life in a
different with the different eyes even
she's young but she suffer you know
she's she's born in Argentina she have
his issues with his family as well
she live alone she have interesting life
and histories as well history and she
helped me a lot she is very mature for
his age we we help each other sometimes
when I'm a little bit down she pushed me
up
and I do it to the other side so we are
a nice couple we help each other so I'm
really pleased that she's in she's on on
my side any any movement on the The
Wedding Bells Christiana I'm not
thinking now about that but I can see in
the future I think I deserve she deserve
but it's something that come not coming
now in my in my plans but in the future
oh yes yes I want
tell me next Wayne Rooney Gary Neville
Ronaldo's got a message for both of you
foreign
[Music]
terrible time in your life
you need to get a new manager Eric
tenhag did you know much about him
a little bit
um
through
ayax the job that I did for
ayax
you end the season with 24 goals for
Manchester United including 18 in the
Premier League six in the Champions
League he was second in the Golden Boot
for the English football I mean by any
normal yardstick that's an incredible
performance
and you were still getting criticized it
was almost like well it's got to be your
fault even though you scored all the
goals were you as bemused as I was that
you were becoming the focal point for
the criticism
I think it's it's easy to point out when
you want to cover other things to put to
point out Cristiano Ronaldo it's it's it
sees everyone now that that press they
wanna
they wanna put me in the first page
because they know they will sell more
the interesting will be different
and I'm used to live like that because
when I was 37
uh I know and I learned many things
um
when you are
in the down of the wave when you are in
the top of the wave it's you don't
realize and you don't see things that
you don't see before which is I
appreciate to have bad moments to see
which people is in your side who
criticize you more because they're
looking for that they don't like to see
successful people the people only try to
bring negativism and I felt the last
four or five months that
not only with for me but even for my
family as well for Georgina
especially
around the world the Press criticized me
even more and sometimes I don't I don't
understand
why even
Portuguese press that they criticize
criticize me a lot
I don't understand but I still believe
that
the jealous is part of that they want to
cover many things that
helps
to to shine other things but listen
Pierce I know I'm 25 21 years in the top
of the game so I know how it takes so
for me it's not a problem it's it's hard
when you are a little bit
down
to listen the CR this criticize do you
read it all do you read newspapers do
you read social media a good thing that
I have it's I don't like to read because
I know
90 of the times they lie they are
garbage they press they are garbage not
all of them but most of them
they don't say the true
um and they're like the constant lie and
the constant attack me and my family
they're always negative reason against
my family
why I'm gonna read because I know they
try to to to make me feel bad me and my
family which is is something hard to
deal but
in the end of the day I understand
but it's it's really really hard the
problem you have is you're too famous
you are the most followed human being on
Instagram that you have I just checked
495 million followers I have just under
2 million on Instagram eight million on
Twitter so I'm catching you on Twitter
slowly but but for one you're nearly at
half a billion followers on Instagram I
mean that's insane
you're bigger than all the Kardashians
put together it's good it's good I feel
proud for that it means it means a lot
for me because
it means that people like me too I'm
charismatic I think
why I'm the number one sometimes asking
ask that questions to myself why me and
not another one why do you think it is
to be honest I not just only because I I
play good football because everyone
knows but I think the rest is is
relevant you have to be charismatic
people have to to feel some connection
with you
I think to be good looking helps too I
have the same book yeah I feel the same
way to be honest because I don't know
the real reason but
I think I'm charismatic and I'm
I'm a pettitive fruit I don't know if we
a fruit that people want to bite yeah I
don't know that the how you can say in
English any particular fruit or
let's say it's strawberry
but I don't know the
the reason I mean what's incredible to
me is the the power you have appetite
appetite appetite appetite fruit
appetite fruit I don't know if it makes
sense in English but if you don't make
sense you learn I'll research appetite
for it yeah I mean I have a pinned tweet
and it's you telling me I have good
abdominals which is a very good
observation and it's only 10 seconds
long it's had 43 million views this clip
so thank you very good 43 million people
have heard the guy who actually has got
good abdominals tell me everybody
abdominals but it showed me that the
sheer Firepower you have in that what in
that world and social media it's just
extraordinary
is is what I what I tell you before
um I have
I have good things which is is you
you can sell your own product let's say
in that way but you have to to deal with
many obstacles in your life too do you
care if people
hate you I mean a lot of people love you
but obviously a lot of people don't
you're so big you're going to get both
but you care about the ones who I care
hate Cristiano right now I care the
people who like me I'm not waste time
for the people who don't like him I
think it's waste of time these these
people they are they are not interested
in my life I like to be a surround
around the people who love me I don't I
don't waste my time to to see the
criticize of people who is next to me
ex-players for example
uh I mean one of your biggest critics
has been and I'm surprised about this me
too Wayne Rooney for example who you
played with for many years very
successfully and we're good friends with
him and yet all this year three or four
times he's come out and attacked you in
the media because I don't understand you
should ask this question to him but
I don't know
um I don't know why you criticized me so
bad or not he says jealous of me says
your behavior is unacceptable United
should sell you you know blah blah blah
blah I mean sweet Rooney it was one year
ago or six months ago here in my house
you pick up his kids here and invite
Christian to go his house to play
football I don't I really don't
understand people like that or if they
want to be in the cover of the of the
paper of the news or the one in your
jobs or whatever
is it jealousy as well perhaps that
you're still playing and still in the
united probably because he finished his
career with 30s so I'm still playing
higher level I'm not gonna say that I'm
looking better than him which is true
but
it's that is inarguable I mean there's
no contest is is hard to listen that
kind of criticize a negative about
people who we play with you for example
getting Neville as well yes I mean Gary
Neville you blanked him the other day uh
on the pitch and he looked quite upset
actually
um because he obviously likes being your
friend but he's been pretty critical of
you as well
can have his own opinion but they don't
really know what's going on for example
inside the the training ground and
Carrington area or even my life they
should listen not only one point of view
they have to listen my point of view as
well because it's easy to to criticize
but if you don't know the old story it's
it's it's easy you know but it's as I
say before it's it's part are they still
friends of yours or do you have a line
where they are not my friends they are
colleagues we play together they they're
not coming we're not ever dinner
together for example
but as I told you appears before it's
part of my journey they kill they keep
criticize me negativism every time so I
follow I continue my my trip and uh I
have to catch up the people who like me
some of your ex colleagues have been
incredibly supportive
Rio Ferdinand has always got your back
Roy Keane always has your back whatever
happens is always supported you and has
continued to do so does that mean a lot
to you it means a lot because they I was
in the dressing room with them they are
part of my journey in football as well
as I mentioned many times rocking for me
was my best Captain ever real Ferd and
it helped me a lot it was my neighbor I
was his neighbor so very very good guys
not just because they speak good about
me but there there was there in a
dressing room they are football players
they know how players thinking and the
behaves
Etc
and to listen Ace X
colleagues or teammates to criticize you
and they always see one point of view do
you feel a bit but do you feel a bit
betrayed when they do that because you
because you played together it's easy
it's easy to criticize I don't know if
you death
a job in television that they must
criticize
to a to be more famous I really don't
understand isn't they use your name a
bit I think they take advantage of that
because they are not stupid and I really
understand and I have to carry on with
my life with criticize criticize or or
when the people speak good about you but
it's art when you see people who was in
the dressing room with you criticizing
that way it must hurt it's not good yes
I do but not hardly I I'm not gonna be
more slim I'm not gonna sleep bad
because of the criticize but it's not
good to listen that disappointing
a little bit yes disappointing
next on our sensored expect fireworks to
the explosive second half of my 90
minutes with Ronaldo
your baby daughters in hospital and the
president of Manchester United didn't
believe the empathy don't exist the
glazes that don't they don't care about
about the club what would your message
be to Manchester United fans the fans
for me will be always in my heart he was
deliberately provoking it I didn't felt
that he had a respect for me Cristiano
Ronaldo has 12 rules to life why not
imagine the rest of the rats they're
gonna criticize you too
I'm just trying to work out how Wayne
Rooney could hate you even more they
only speak about the black Chip which is
his name they're trying to force you out
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys they are around
the club yes I feel betrayed if you
don't have respect for me I'm never
gonna have respect for you you think
England have a have a chance have a
chance beside Portugal in my opinion
that's it you retire right yeah I'll
retired 100
[Music]
thank you
you won't want to miss it whatever
you're up to keep it uncensored
[Music]
thank you